irène chaigneau propose voyage sans
passeport
m
sap et caprices d'un des murs je vous
défie à l'impossible chaos naît la
beauté
sur cette terre l'homme a construit une
ville ça vide topographie ambitieuse un
peu folle
elle conduit d'abord l'européen l
angoisse et même à une sorte de vertige
il imprègne peu à peu de ce fameux
sodano ce qu'aucun autre horizon ne sera
facilement comblé le corcovado on
l'atteint par sainte thérèse et
silvestre ou par ses troupes
celle de la rentrée grâce
au bas de ses flancs abrupts la ville se
blottit
de ce sommet de mieux me christ et blanc
de land of steel
corcovado n'est pas le point le plus
élevé de la sierra de cariocas elle est
couverte d'une végétation brésilienne
c'est à dire c'est à dire qu'une de
vitalité mais aussi destructrice que les
sables du désert
le brésil est grand mais la télévision
fait des miracles de la serra da caillou
cas nous voici en amazonie l'amazone le
monde amazonien piette sursis payer les
nénuphars ne souhaite pas être originaux
mais puisque là-bas tout est grand
pourquoi ne serait-il pas oui alors il
supporte allègrement un enfant de la
faune amazonienne tortues iguanes
panthères auxquels s'ajoutent des
oiseaux bruyant chan avait des singes du
nombre de bêtes dit quand j'écris
mais l'homme l'homme là bas et bien
c'est l'indien il attire et il désespère
le chercheur d' aventure il vit par
groupe s'éteint progressivement et
suivant sa tribu hostile au contact des
blancs ou bien elle les ignore ou bien
il est au contraire très sociable
but
battre les aux bases de la vie viennent
d'où se dégage une substance toxique qui
engourdit le poisson nous oblige à prêts
à les piquer avec nos flèches
oui c'est un jeune indien
iguaçu c'est aussi une frontière celle
du brésil et de l'argentine
et c'est un affluent du pareil n'ya que
nous devons ça gradins au de 60 mètres
chute qui éclabousse un puissant
amphithéâtre basaltiques
mais tout n'est pas si violent cette eau
qui dort presque donne raison au
proverbe il ne faut pas s'y fier
elle est pleine de surprises diamant
aucun se joignent aux bases aigue-marine
améthyste
ici trois éléments se sont mis d'accord
pour servir l'homme l'eau la terre le
feu la terre porte aux locales de celle
le soleil brûle et fait évaporer l'eau
alors la terre porte le sel
l'offre à l'homme qui dit brésil dit
aussi gaucci pour la plupart d'origine
portugaise ses hommes à cheval grand
buveur de maths et bruyant bagarreurs
ont fini par se fixer davantage au sol
et un aussi transformé leur vie
pastorale rudimentaire on un élevage
scientifique fort lucratif
bien sûr ce sont des caféiers
le café brésilien doit son arôme
spéciale à cette terre brunâtre et
santos et la porte océane de l' empire
du café on récolte aux portes de sao
paulo 6 à 800 mètres d'altitude sao
paulo et plus blanche que noir très
différente de rios qui est beaucoup plus
pittoresques plus paresseuse sao paulo
c'est la ville de la lutte du travail
ses habitants sont pour beaucoup fils
d'italiens d'allemands dechy rien de
japonais sao paulo est une des villes
qui la nuit ressemble probablement le
plus à chicago
c'est une grande ville moderne son âme
ne se livre qu'à celui toulouse
longtemps
le problème de l'enfance est un problème
brûlant au brésil on tente beaucoup pour
eux
et pour éviter tout chi
on fait dans la mesure du possible cela
ce qui est évidemment beaucoup mieux
dans l'extraordinaire creuset qui est un
monde moderne celui ci frappe au maximum
par son absence de racisme toutes les
couleurs toutes les origines un seul
ennemi le climat il est rare en effet de
voir d'aussi vieux visages on n'atteint
pas souvent là bas un âge avancé
espérons que pour cela le problème sera
d'une façon ou d'une autre
résolus
la presque pauvreté n'empêche pas la
joie ou même la provoc que c'est plus
facile dans ce pays où il ne fait jamais
fois
chaque année revient le même phénomène
populaire carnaval dont les éléments
essentiels sont le rythme
les défilés de travestis les instruments
à percussion
la balle enfants soient très tôt que de
la vie à la mort il n'ya qu'un jeu et
qu'il lui faudra le jouer seul
c'est peut-être pourquoi de la folie
carnavalesque au délire religieux il ya
si peu de distance
là bas ont pris comme on respire
on se chie par habitude
c'est une fois à l'échelle de la
végétation puissante délirante
je n'oserais dire abusive et puis voici
le baiia toute douce tout ancien tout en
songe accroupi prêt de saab et son port
envahi de barques rutilante chargé
d'orange ou de banane ces vieux murs ont
défendu comme ils ont pu l'ancienne
capitale du brésil
aujourd'hui il monte la garde celle du
souvenir
bahia est gâté elle a deux villes
la haute et la basse ce qui explique ses
rues en pente
poterie joli mais poreuse
bahia pêcheurs marc guitard langoustes
et l'infini des voiles
et des palmiers pays paisible
et qui pourtant interroge le ciel
cette émission a été réalisée avec le
concours de daniel meyer de l'ambassade
du brésil à paris et le solange péters
photographies de gens mangent ont animé
par samia vite ski montage claude
richard sont jean belloc